In the spa town of Buxton
in Darbryshire, England
there is a beautiful blue lagoon
it looks like a great place to go swimming
but you might want to read the signs first
The blue lagoon of Buxton
looks like something that was plucked out of the Caribbean
and dropped into the English countryside
it’s in an old limestone quarry
that’s been left abandoned
it’s filled in with this magical azure colored water
people love to go swimming there
they take little boats there
you can see youtube videos of people doing flips
and jumping into the blue lagoon of Buxton
there’s some things you should know about the blue lagoon
before you get into it
One sign reads
Warning! Polluted Water. Water is known to contain
Car wrecks, rubbish, dead animals, excrement
Dangerous to swim in due to high pH levels
this can cause skin and eye irritation
fungal infections, thrush, it can cause thrush
general grossness
Think! Would you swim in ammonia or bleach?
and I’m going to guess the answer is probably not
so the water is not as beautiful and crystalline and pure
as it might appear on first glance
but people go swimming there every summer
without fail
this really started to irritate the locals of Buxton
which is in and of itself a small quaint spa town
so it probably rubbed them the wrong way
that people weren’t going to the spas
but were going to swim in an abandoned limestone quarry
that was filled with garbage
and as they kept telling people
the blue lagoon of Buxton has a pH level of 11.2
ammonia has a pH level of 11.3
these are super alkaline substances
it’s like diluted bleach
bleach has an alkaline level of only 12.6
which isn’t a lot higher on the scale when you consider that
normal water is at a level 7
so the townspeople talked about various solutions
draining it wasn’t really an option
because it constantly refills with rain water
they also talked about filling it in
but the cost and the effort was just prohibitive
so they came up with a more novel solution
they dyed the lagoon black
and in fact, it worked
according to locals people stopped coming to swim in the lagoon
instead of looking like this beautiful little island paradise
it looked like a cesspool
it looked like a pit of doom and despair
which is exactly what they wanted it to look like
so it was kind of a genius plan
but there is one problem, they did this in 2013
as of right now
the lagoon has gone back to it’s original beautiful blue color
and it’s only a matter of time
before the families and the tourists
start flocking to take a swim in the blue lagoon of Buxton
Subscribe here
and watch more videos here
I think that there is something else going on here
which is that I don’t think the local towns people were so so concerned
about the well being of the people
who were going and swimming in this abandoned quarry
maybe they felt like it was a lawsuit waiting to happen
although frankly that was on the quarry owners
I think it was more that it was kind of embarrassing
and it was becoming so popular that it was clogging the streets
and taking up parking
and there is nothing that pisses off a small towner more
than when outsiders come and steal all the parking